بعد تصويت البرلمان الباكستاني لسحب الثقه
منه نجح رئيس الوزراء عمران خان لعده اشهر
بتجنب الاعتقال بتوهام الفساد وقضى انصاره
في بعض الاحيان معارك ضاريه مع الشرطه
لابقائه خارج الاحتجاز يوم الثلاثاء
الماضي اظهرت لقطات دراميه العشرات من
افراد الامن وهم يخرجون خان الذي يبلغ
عمره سبعين عاما يخرجونه بالقوه من
المحكمه ثم يضعونه في سياره للشرطه
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
امام محكمه معنيه بالقضايا قضايا الفساد
في مجمع الشرطه بالعاصمه اسلام اباد قاضي
المحكمه اعاده الى الحجز لمده ثمانيه ايام
على ذمه قضيه القادر تراست هي قضيه فساد
منفصله تتعلق بنقل مزعوم لارض لجامعه
القدر القريبه من اسلام اباد
ثاني وجه عشرات القضايا المرفوعه عليه
رسميا وتهى من عديد اهمها قضيه توشخانه او
صندوق الهدايا
التي صدر بوجوبها امر بتوقيف عمران بتهام
بيع بعض الهدايا التي اهديت اليه وهو في
منصبه هذا الامر ممنوع قانونا في القانون
الباكستاني السهمه الثانيه تهمه الارهاب
والتحريض على القتل بسبب تخريب الممتلكات
العامه احتجاجا على قرار لجنه الانتخابات
التهمه الثالثه هي التمويل المحظور حققت
لجنه الانتخابات في تلقي حزبه انصاف
تحويلات ماليه بملايين الدولارات من
الخارج اما بالنسبه للرابعه فهي التحريض
على قتل احد قيادات حزب الرابطات
الاسلاميه الباكستانيه وهو جناح نواس شريف
حزب اسعاف الذي يراسه خان علق على اعتقاله
يقول رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
اختطف ولم يعتقل يجب الاستمرار بنزول الى
الشارع حتى الافراج عنه وزير الداخليه
الباكستانيه ارانا ثناء الله عل على قضيه
اعتقال عمران خان بالقول اعتقل عمران خان
في قضيه فساد ولا استثناء من مع من يهاجم
الدوله تقررت اتخاذ اجراءات صارمه ضد
الارهابيين السياسيين
وافراد العصابات اما بالنسبه للرئيس
الباكستاني عارف علوي فقال قلق للغايه
بشان الوضع الحالي في البلاد بسبب اعتقال
وضرب رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان ان
الخساره في الارواح الناتجه عن ذلك هي
خساره مفجعه ومخيفه وماساويه ومدامه بشده
انتشرت اعمال شغب واشتباكات بين الشرطه
ومتظاهرين في
مدينتي لاهور وكراتشي وايضا اسفرت
الاشتباكات عن مقتل اربعه اشخاص واصابه 85
في بيشاور
مايكل نبينا
كيف علق جمهورهم منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
في العالم العربي عندما علموا باعتقال خان
ما هي تحليلاتهم ابداوا من سميه تقول لك
اعتقال عمران وبطريقه مهينه
مقلوبه هناك ومظاهرات وتفجيرات بالتاكيد
لارهاب الشعب الثائر قصه مخابراتيه قديمه
وماروسه لكن هذا شعب اعتقد انه سيعطي درسا
لجيشه التابع للغرب على يقول عمران خان
زعيم شعبوي لا يمكن السيطره عليه من
الدوله العميقه الباكستانيه
بالتعاون مع الجيش قررت الحكومه تعجيل
تفجير المشهد الباكستاني باعتقال عمران
خان حتى تكون لها زمام المبادره في
السيطره على الاوضاع وبالفعل انطلقت
المظاهرات شيباني قال لك شيباني عمران كان
مجرد لاعب كريكت ثم
في المشهد السياسي الباكستاني ليكون قائد
عدم الاستقرار في باكستان اخر تغريده في
القصه اتت من هادي يقول لها احد يستطيع ان
يعارض الغرب او يقف في وجه امريكا لقد كان
خطا استراتيجيا من طرف هؤلاء ربما ليست
لديهم خبره في السياسه واضاف الحاسه
الاستراتيجيه لديهم فقد كان لاعب
المحكمه العليا في باكستان قالت ان اعتقال
عمران خان لم يكن قانونيا ولذا يجب اطلاق
سراحه